Here's something strange about you. You
love yourself more than anyone else on
this planet. You would protect yourself,
feed yourself, fight for yourself. But
here's what's strange. You trust other
people's opinions of you more than your
own. Am I good enough? You don't answer
that. You wait for them to answer it.
Think about that. You would sacrifice
almost anything for your own well-being,
but you won't sacrifice 5 seconds of
comfort for your own authenticity.
Why? Because you inherited a nervous
system built for a world that no longer
exists. Your brain still treats a
negative comment like a predator
sighting. It treats being unfollowed
like being cast out. That's not
weakness. That's outdated programming.
But here's the liberation. There is no
you who is conditioned. There is only
conditioning. And conditioning can be
seen. You don't need to find yourself.
You need to stop abandoning yourself.